The Muppets are back and they dance like
this ah it's actually exhausting don't
Muppets oh it's been years since the
Muppets have been on screen and when I
saw a trailer for this movie I was like
this is awesome this is hilarious my one
concern will people even remember or
care and I really hope soaks when you
see this movie you're like they're still
relevant or so the story goes in this
movie as it is in real life it's been
years since the Muppets have been
together they haven't kept in touch and
now they need to come together for their
comeback show and everyone's like the
who for the what and I loved how this
movie played on that who's in the movie
they dressed the fact I like yeah it's
no one cares and there are things about
the Muppets movies like before that they
could get away with but now if you put
them in you're like does that work like
you know musical numbers things like
that and I liked how this movie just
addressed the fact that yeah it's absurd
if you're doing a movie like this so
like I don't know that that would work
with audiences today so we're going to
do it we're going to address the fact
that yeah it is absurd to do that so
that was awesome they played to their
strengths and in that they breached the
fourth wall a few times if you don't
know what that is pretty much when the
characters acknowledge that yeah we're
in a movie and yeah there's the audience
and I'll talk to the audience sometimes
even you know like when Fozzie Bear was
all like that was a really big explosion
surprise we had that in the budget my
only gripe about it is that they do it
quite a few times you know when you do
it a couple times it's so special in
Solaris when you end up doing it a lot
in a movie it's still funny but it
ceases to be special at that point and
all the Muppets are ending all the ones
you remember you got Kermit Miss Piggy
the great gonzo those two old guys that
gripe on the balcony that one dude that
looks like a big plush couch they're all
in it and actually there's a new Muppet
or he's a puppet I guess the Muppets are
like the group he's an aspiring to be
muppet he's Jason Siegel's brother and
he's really the one that gets his whole
ball rolling for their comeback show if
I had to place the humor in this movie
this humor reminded me of the show
community it's like yeah you really
appreciate it if you're into pop culture
and you get movie references things like
that but the Muppets are back they're
still hilarious they're still relevant
which I am psyched for them and I was
afraid I was gonna go into this movie
and just be like it's just too little
too late for this but in the end I loved
it it's one of those movies you love the
more you think about it I'll say it this
way this is the best Muppets movie that
a Muppets movie could be if it came out
now in 2011 after a lot of people have
forgotten about the Muppets I will not
only buy this movie
on blu-ray this makes me want to go out
and just buy all the other Muppets
movies on blu-ray so who is your
favorite Muppet of all of them comment
below let me know mine dude it's got to
be animal okay I love control the best
I'm telling you I didn't love gonzo
though he's great I remember he was like
my childhood favorite and as I grew up I
was like I just like unstable Muppets
animal and I loved enlightening you guys
two really cool podcasts and this is a
podcast for film fans what you guys will
probably are I put a link below to a
podcast where schmoes know interviewed
the editor-in-chief of Rotten Tomatoes
Matt at UT they talked about a lot of
film stuff which I personally like but
they also talked about the prospect of
rotten tomatoes actually recognizing
YouTube movie reviewers as official
critics which I personally love so check
it out be entertained my film fans and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more I love control
[Music]